c'est un objet devenu précieux avec le
confinement
le papier toilette
voici quelques usages détournés de cet
objet devenu rare dans les rayons 1976
un rouleau de pq pour un bizutage
princier le prince charles d'angleterre
fait ses adieux à la marine britannique
à la royal navy
ça n'a pas empêché d'être bizuté selon
la grande tradition de la marine royale
je vous laisse regarder
car si le ridicule tue en france il
grandit peut-être en angleterre 1993
toulouse pour les phobiques et
administratifs se sert pas des ondes
coûts devraient se servir et c'est un
papier tôt à la feuille d'impôt pour les
autres ça c'est pour ceux très drôle je
vous à nous vous le ferons
alors pour tous les récalcitrants aux
apo et bien voyez ce qu'ils font avec
valable aussi pour qu'un aveugle faire
un casque de bigoudène et à la bretonne
1998 un guide touristique à lire aux
toilettes pour quelqu'un qui a travaillé
des mois et des mois sur ce projet c'est
pas un peu frustrant finalement de
travailler sur du jetable là sinon je
pense c'est tout le contraire je crois
que bon d'une part c'est utile c'est
quelque chose de la vie de chaque jour
et puis si c'est agréable en plus c'est
un plus et je crois jeter des choses
dont on s'est servi d'une façon
sympathique et ans cultive je pousse un
fantastique et 1999 la mariée made in
vst c3 avant papier en papier toilette
en papier hygiénique pour voir les
choses comme elles sont on a quand même
essayé de ne pas trop insister
on avait fait les coiffures avec des
rouleaux on a pensé que c'était quand
même un tout petit peu trop
[Musique]